we've got a bit of breaking news to
bring you now we're going straight to
the old bailey around the corner from
here some breaking news in the last few
minutes this has come from the
central criminal court uh wayne cousins
has pleaded guilty to the murder
of sarah everard cousins is a 48 year
old metropolitan police officer
he's already pleaded guilty to sarah
everard's rape and murder sarah everard
was 33
and was abducted when walking on clapham
common in southwest london
in march straight now to sky's crime
correspondent martin brunt for the
latest martin
well the trial that was scheduled for
october now isn't going to happen
because wayne cousins
has in the last few seconds pleaded
guilty to the murder
of sarah everard a month ago in the same
court here
he'd already pleaded guilty to
raping and kidnapping her but hadn't
until today
been asked formally to plead to the
third charge he faced
of murdering her but he's just done that
so he's admitted
all the three charges he faced
he's not here in court he's appeared by
video link from belmar prison
where he's been held since his arrest in
early march
he mutches on previous appearances
has struck a rather forlorn figure he's
sitting on a red bench
bearded shaved head as before
hunched forward his hands clasped
together between his legs
and staring at the floor the
hearing opened at 10 30 and within two
minutes or so
he had been asked to um to make that
plea now there are
or there have been certain reporting
restrictions uh
on proceeding so far um we
still haven't had uh officially any
detail
of uh of what uh what happened um
on the night of sarah's murder but we do
have some idea
of sarah everard's uh movements
and of course some of the movements of
wayne cousins
who's just admitted her murder so sarah
everard
went missing on the 3rd of march
reported
the next day as missing by her boyfriend
she
lived in brixton had visited a friend in
nearby clapham
had been walking home to brixton a
rather circuitous route
around clapham common and then just
vanished and her body was found 10 days
later
50 miles away in woodland near ashford
in woodland that was very close 100
meters or so
from land that was owned by wayne
wayne cousins he'd already been arrested
by that stage apparently
t uh telephone footage uh telephone
cell site analysis had located him
um at that site um he initially
made no comment to police but eventually
last month pleaded guilty to kidnap
and rape of sarah everard and of course
this was a
case that caused widespread shock and
condemnation
not just publicly but within the
metropolitan police
itself and the commissioner cressida
dick
even in the early stages of wayne
cousins arrest
had talked about the shock and anger
within the force
now having heard his final guilty plea
to sarah everard's
murder this morning we are expecting
that commissioner cressida dick
will have more to say wayne cousins had
been a metropolitan police officer
for three years before that it worked
for the civil nuclear
constabulary hadn't been a police
officer long for long had worked as a
mechanic
in his family's business
in dover that business collapsed he
became a police officer
and at the time of this murder when he
committed this murder
he was a pc and serving as an armed
officer within the
protection diplomatic and parliamentary
protection unit
at scotland yard he was off duty on the
night
he snatched sarah everard off the street
and later murdered her he is still
currently a serving police officer but
since his earlier guilty pleas
he hasn't been paid by the force and um
it must be inevitable now that he will
face
inevitable misconduct hearing and
be sacked by the metropolitan police but
we'll hear more
from crested dick sometime in the next
hour we think